John Aaron Sports Business Journal a
Sports Business Journal reporter and has
been there with the sports business
since 2006 and John I wanted to have you
on because you know we're an unchartered
territory here with these leagues
hitting the pause button here but you
know when you start to look at this the
trickle down with you know people who
work at the stadiums and jerseys and you
know concessions I mean they're there's
so much of an impact that how do you
quantify the impact that this is going
to have on the sports world gosh that's
an impossible question to answer because
the trickle down even goes as far as
let's say they start let's say the NBA
starts up the playoffs after 30 days
which is you know a possibility how many
people are going to go and sit and sit
in the stands there and so also you have
attendance problems you were on the
doorstep of a recession right now how
many advertisers are still going to be
paying these top dollars to get sort of
get their message messaging out a cross
that you have you know a you know
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
rights fees in the NCAA tournament which
is just not being played now like how is
that going to become a whole now with
CBS and Turner which just told me they
sold a record number record high revenue
against that tournament field this band
has been for me one of the most um oh
well just a wild week for anybody but in
particular in terms of reporting on the
sports business
I got to talk to top people at all the
networks all the league's all the other
teams nobody knows anything nobody knows
what's going on nobody knows what it's
going to look like week from now two
weeks from now or a month from now and
everybody's just sort of like it's just
like it's not even a holding pattern
things changed just so quickly and and
they're just trying to react more than
then plan out and you also have the NCAA
tournament of course that was canceled
but I I was wondering the amount of
money that's made there
what happens with that money or who is
going to pay the price of not having
that money come from March Madness with
schools in terms of right now the
network's as you know paid pay the
n-c-double-a and so that those two are
going to have to get together and figure
out concealable a promise a tournament
there's not going to be a tournament so
see guess and turner are going to need
to get that money back it's almost
certain that there's not going to be a
rebate to where they're going to as NC
double-a is going to cut a check to them
but they're going to have to sort of
make good elsewhere maybe increase the
deal going forward and what's going to
end up happening there is that you know
the schools aren't going to get as much
money because it's a it's kind of it's
just going to be a trickle-down effect
down to what you were talking about
think about think about like the person
that created the the magazine souvenir
magazines everybody buys at the at the
stadiums I mean those magazines were all
produced right I would imagine and all
of a sudden you know something a
business like that is you know really
out significantly on this the XFL had to
shut down it feels like Vince McMahon
was maybe looking at this at least as a
three year project I don't have numbers
on that but but it feels like there was
a three year process here of he was he
had money that he was going to lose a
knew he was going to lose but what kind
of impact will this have on the XFL yeah
I think I'm gonna answer every question
of yours with nobody knows and I
apologize for that but nobody knows but
one thing one thing is that everybody
said that the XFL was prepared to go to
year two they were going to be financed
through year two they have sort of media
deals in place that go multiple years
they had sponsorship deals in place ago
multiple years and so the that the
likelihood is that that they will kick
off a second year the question is
everybody saw what happened with their
401ks everybody sees what's happening
with the stock market so that money that
was around to to fund
year two how is that affected and that's
sort of yeah we're going through my
story list coming up of stories that I
need to research and that's that's going
to be one of them
the Masters has been postponed this year
they obviously can take this financial
hit but what about CBS with that you
know CBS losing out on the masters and
you know now they've lost out on March
Madness as well they they have is there
insurance here is there like what would
kind of you know act of God insurance
here there certainly will be some
insurance here but the network's and are
gonna are going to have to get together
with the leaks or the conferences or the
n-c-double-a and just try to I think
because the the network's could demand
their money back right but at the same
time the network's
have deals with cable systems and the
cable system that the the TNT deal with
their cable system is all predicated on
showing the n-c-double-a tournament so
so there's a whole different there's a
whole line of business dealings that are
sort of in upheaval now and the one
thing that I heard this week and is that
everybody kind of wants to work together
so it's not gonna it's not gonna blow up
to where you know I'm gonna have a good
front-page story of a he-said she-said
but that's right now I mean what happens
in a month when they really start to
feel the pinch so that that that's
another sort of area that work that I'm
going to be looking at as well what
league is most vulnerable financially
right now the newer ones that I like the
XFL that you mentioned I would never
call the NFL vulnerable and the NFL is
is so powerful but one thing you have to
look at is that there they were right on
the cusp of starting a media rights
negotiation that was going to bring in
you know 60 to 70 percent more in
revenue from from the network's the
networks are not a charity case you know
the network's also their stocks fall as
well and they're looking at a prospect
of less advertising now like how much
does that affect the the NFL moving
forward again knowing no real answers
but these are a lot of
questions that people are having but
you're also looking at this NFL
situation with the timing of this if and
I was told by somebody with the Players
Association that the owners felt like a
recession was coming before the
coronavirus the timing of trying to get
a TV deal done how important is that to
the NFL is it do it now or do you try to
ride this out I think that one of the
things that they were trying to do
because of the TV deal isn't up for a
couple of years they are really trying
to to beat any kind of recession that
that was coming I mean there was a they
were going whole hog to get this done
and it looked like things would be sort
of in place if not signed by the fall
and now you know it I haven't I don't
know anything but my speculation is that
this this could then be pushed back in
another year so just to let everybody
get their footing again and then I look
at the NBA with at least a month off and
then you look at the fallout from what
happened with Darrell Maurice comments
about China it's been a constantly year
for the NBA yeah and what if they don't
play they don't have playoffs because
you know right now a lot of these deals
that the league's have with the
network's Dan are predicated on a number
of games or a number of hours that have
been shown and almost certainly I don't
know that the any of the NHL and the NBA
through the regular season have met that
number of hours so they're they're okay
right now in terms of their contractors
and triggering clauses but the the
playoffs are coming if they don't play
the playoffs that that is a huge thing I
mean that's something that they're going
to try to to stay away from but if you
saw Adam Silver's comments yesterday on
TNT like he said 30 days or more or less
like nobody everybody's waiting to see
what their what everything's going to
look like in 30 days so the idea that
it's going to be a rigid 30 days is
fanciful right now Jon great to talk to
you hope you have a great weekend safe
weekend and thanks for joining us I wish
I could be more optimistic than I
apologize for that
yeah that's not your fault Thank You Jon
Jon I ran to the Sports Business Journal